and as the president heads overseas vice
president kamala harris is back in
washington
after her trip to mexico and guatemala
she met with mexico's president and
others to talk about the root causes of
the immigration crisis but
she faces criticism from both parties on
capitol hill
ed o'keefe is just back from guatemala
city he was with the vice president ed
good morning to you
so why the incoming for vice president
harris from
the republicans and the democrats now
good morning gail immigration is a
sensitive subject on both sides of the
border and here in washington on both
sides of the aisle
it's been her big focus ever since the
president assigned her to take it on in
march
on this trip the vice president
announced new plans to tackle illegal
border crossings
and took on issues like drug trafficking
and political corruption
but some critics say she's ignoring what
they think is the most important issue
the border itself we need to
prioritize what's happening at the
border and we have to prioritize why
people are going to the border
at a press conference tuesday night in
mexico vice president harris said she
will visit the u.s border with mexico in
the future
i think it's short-sighted to suggest
we're only going to
respond to the reaction as opposed to
addressing the cost
harris hasn't been to the border since
the president tasked her with handling
the increasing number of migrants
journalists repeatedly questioned her
about this on her trip
we've been to the border we've been to
the border you haven't been to the
border
and i haven't been to europe republican
critics like texas senator john cornyn
called her out
for skipping the stop she hasn't even
been to
our southern border she hasn't visited
the facilities where tens of thousands
of migrant children
have been cared for biden administration
officials defended and clarified
harris's work
her assignment was to work with
countries and leaders in the northern
triangle to address root causes
address corruption ensure we're working
together to address humanitarian
concerns
but the vice president's message to
migrants wanting to come to the u.s
do not come was also criticized by some
fellow democrats
new york's alexandria ocasio-cortez
called those comments
disappointing saying we can't help set
someone's house on fire
and then blame them for fleeing look
this issue of whether or not to go to
the borders rooted in pure politics
the gop knows harris remains a popular
rival and may one day run for president
herself
the vice president for her part viewed
the trip as a success and she did
demonstrate an ability to go toe-to-toe
with world leaders
but her inability to more quickly bat
away a criticism from gop critics
clouded the focus of the trip
all of this tony yet another reminder of
how hard it will be to achieve consensus
on the issue of immigration meanwhile
there are millions of lives in the
balance ed thank you very much